what's up you guys this is a livestream
about Pakistan for my experiences in the
country I want to connect with you guys
talk about what I came into it's gonna
be great for Pakistanis that want to see
that outside perspective that outside
perspective but also for travelers that
are looking to go to Pakistan I can
share some of my knowledge of my
experience along the way so getting into
it off the gunwale last livestream
didn't go well because I did it right in
the middle of Ramadan and the livestream
for Facebook dived hardcore so we're
giving a round to for those that missed
out Cindy I am well thank you
so indian pakistan comparison a little
political is that true okay so guys i
just did a video recently comparing
Indian and Pakistan similarities in
differences I try to keep politics out
of my content for the most part but
you're you're gonna step over the line
at times there's there's no way around
that
so was it political I don't think too
political but maybe you know everything
can be political right but I didn't go
into like different policies by the
government's or anything like that
obviously out of you know just when I go
into politics it all turns to hell
really it all my my work goes out of
context really trying to show I mean the
whole purpose of this work guys is to
show like it started you know from a
from my perspective like I want to show
the world in a cool way these places
were taught to fear not to go to that's
what I was talking up in the US and what
can I do you know this this is what
fires me out this is my passion to show
these places that I've seen firsthand in
a good way like how do i how do i bring
that message across so when i dive in a
politics man that usually goes south
so guys I am doing this on my phone and
my computer so bear with me if my eyes
leave the phone for a bit because well
this camera right here because I can't
really see the messages on here they're
going too quickly alright guys I am all
question I'm I'm all about taking
questions giving the answers that I got
opinions and then let's just share a
conversation let's just you know
whatever you guys want to talk about I'm
there for those that you for those of
you who have not seen my work I did a 10
part series on Pakistan and I have one
more coming I have one more episode
coming Sunday and this is the best of
Pakistan it's sort of an overview of my
trip condensed version of all the all
the episodes why didn't I come to skardu
last time good question when you travel
a country like I only had two weeks I
had a two week window you got to make
your choices I pushed a pretty quick
pace throughout the country I wanted to
get the big cities I wanted to get
Peshawar which is a big city and I
wanted to get some of the mountains and
I chose Hansa i Noda I've known of honza
since I was a college student honza and
SWAT those were the two valleys I knew
of so I picked honza will I ever visit
Pakistan again yes for sure
I really two weeks in the country is not
much I try to dive in as deep as I could
meet as many people as I could learn as
much as I could but really look as a
foreigner I'll never get it like a local
I'll see things people at locals don't
see but they'll know and see things that
I'll never know right it's one of those
countries I have to return to because I
it's piqued my interest my off-time now
I'm I'm online researching things about
Pakistan so that's when I know I've been
to a place that I want to return to so
yes definitely go back there Pakistani
visa process how hard was that easy
super easy
now I have a US passport and an Italian
passport so the US passport there are a
few more hurdles I think I had I think
you have to go to like an embassy and go
that route it's more of a process the
Italian passport I did it online printed
out a piece of paper showed up at the
border right over you can see in the my
first episode what I call it first day
in Pakistan I think going over the
border from India to Pakistan I just
gave the guy a piece of paper he looked
at my passport it was super easy was
what was very interesting though that
was the first border checkpoint and then
you go inside a building
now Pakistani intelligence is notorious
for having a good ear to the ground
let's say and I met a guy in the
immigrations place who was very friendly
right he just he just started talking to
me like a friend asking Thank You K
Thank You K for that super shot really
appreciate that and ask me another
question K I'm working on this phone
unfortunately and I can't open those up
if you have a question and if you don't
well thanks anyways okay so in the in
customs this guy starts talking to me
and he's like oh hey he knew the u.s.
really well he knew a lot about the lot
of cultural nuances he knew about
California really well and I'm not
talking like Hollywood stuff or you know
you know basic cultural stuff that
everyone knows like he actually had some
really good knowledge conversation
calling a lot of phishing questions sort
of like seeing what I was doing there
what my intentions were there it was
really interesting I don't feel like I
was followed in the country a lot of
people say that like the ISA is actually
following perhaps at times I'm not sure
but they're excellent LLB thank you
really appreciate that and guys again if
you're doing these super chats I think
this is only my third live I've ever
done so I will really try my hardest to
answer the super chats because look you
guys are all supporting my work really
appreciate that but the peep
actually giving money to I definitely
got to answer their questions and I
didn't do that last time so I'm a very
cute I up for this okay even if they're
following you probably to make sure you
are safe yeah that's what I've heard
look you take a country like Pakistan
that's only receive negative exposure in
Western media they're trying to build
tourism if one guy one American guy gets
kidnapped gets runs into a lot of
trouble that hits the news you know the
news they're like you know CNN and BBC
they're like parasites they'll be on
that immediately and then all the sudden
the narrative for Pakistan changes of
Pakistan is dangerous to travel to so
that's the reason I get it like they got
to be on it and I think they're doing a
good job as I say in my upcoming video
I'm posting Sunday the the police on the
rangers are fantastic to deal with as a
tourist I don't know how corrupt behind
the scenes things are I'm sure there's
some levels of corruption here and I'm
not acting like I know how these
institutions work but uh thanks I'll be
but as a traveler it's always a
different perspective as a traveler
they're very easy to deal with and I
think a lot I think the Rangers and the
cops correct me if I'm wrong Pakistanis
on like on the street level they seem
like they're pretty well in order I
don't think they're bought off I don't
think they're paid off so I live in
Ukraine of American literally live in
Ukraine in Kiev the capital the the
police force has cleaned up a lot it
used to be you could buy off everything
or the cops and I think it's still you
know you get out of the capital a little
bit and you get pulled over you can
pretty much you know buy off anything in
this country so every country is
different with that right MTL thank you
I appreciate that that donation if you
got a question especially all of you I'm
going to try my best here but the super
chatters who are giving me money of
course I have to answer your questions
I'll do my best here lb thank you
brother
appreciate
alvey's on fire right now that's his
third a super chat donation Wow true fan
how cheap was Pakistan food was super
cheap Street food very cheap
transportation cheap hotels
I am look I had done India for two weeks
before Pakistan and then two weeks in
Pakistan and I was pretty much making a
video almost every day so when you're
traveling it's one thing when you're
making a video and going in a totally
strange lb is out-of-control
lb I hope you're not drinking because
I'll have to give you all this money
back I think you got a question here no
you don't okay so the hotel's I wanted
to stay it's sort of a nicer level then
probably a step up from what I usually
stand so that's still cheap looking Bert
of Western standards it's like I was
paying I think 60 bucks a night or
something like that for a nice
comfortable room that was my biggest
expense other than that it's it's pretty
inexpensive to travel you know if you're
coming in from you know with a harder
currency great thank you guys all these
questions it's really cool I'm gonna try
my best to get to all of you
moderators for this chat yeah that's
that's a good suggestion
moon social media to use at the moment
moon is a great fan thank you for
reaching out moon from Iran what social
media D is look I YouTube pays so I have
to I've actually made the jump from
telling my business and going full in on
making content so YouTube pays Facebook
demonetized me instant Instagram doesn't
pay so at this
this juncture it's YouTube's the number
one I got to get better at the Instagram
in facebook but as far as a mediator
goes yeah I'm a one-man band at this
time so guys I appreciate it you know
the follows because my Instagram is not
beautiful it's not winning any awards
for lob is on fire thank you I'll be
okay some other questions
would you be willing to do a collab with
my friend from the UK he's been keen on
visiting Pakistan it depends I'm down
with collabs if they like if they match
really well like if our interests align
but contact at Peter Santaniello comm he
can hit me up their hotel booking
details to get your online visas did I
have to provide those I think I think I
did one and I did it on Orbitz and then
I cancelled just to get that information
I think that's how I did it but I don't
remember exactly okay another super chat
guys really appreciate these I'm gonna
try to hit all of them and boom here we
go do I have to provide hotel booking
detail okay I got that one I missed one
sorry hit me up again did I feel unsafe
or followed confronted I did not feel
unsafe but I you know with my content I
try to what I want my audience so I want
you guys to feel that raw on-the-ground
authentic not planned feel and that's
that's to me what's interesting if I had
everything or a driver at the border
going into Pakistan and everything just
laid out it I just don't think would be
interesting content there there are
other people that could do that way
better than me
they'd make beautiful brown shots hit
more of the sights all that stuff I'm
not going to compete with that what I
like to do is like the stories I've been
telling people my whole life no this
place is cool no these people are cool I
want to show in its truest form so your
question was did I feel did it feel
unsafe no let me think going into
Peshawar no not Peshawar Lahore the
first day I mean I'm not a place for
sure I'm at a place as a foreigner and
then I'm at a place as a guy holding a
camera speaking English into it so
there's like a double-double out of
place 'no stew it lb is on fire elby's
stop this man stop him he's going to be
broke by the end of the super chair so
as far as feeling safe Lahore I felt
safe you know I walked around a corner
there's these you can see in the video
they're these guy
with these uh I don't know kind of gun
that was but they had guns and there are
protecting gold there were gold shops
there and the guy invited me over it
gave me some tea his buddy had to get on
the guy in front of me had a gun so you
just I was hit with these things quickly
and I love that feeling that's to me one
of the best feelings everyone needs
their drug on this planet whatever it is
mine is going in totally out of my
element and trying to figure it out okay
super chet thank you what did I feel
about the Pashtun 's you guys call them
puffins is this correct I always thought
it was the pass jeans but I've seen two
two different names they're actually
talked about in my next video I'm
posting Sunday they are all loved or or
all war they are very passionate if you
come in as as a friend as an ally
it's like leverage you think of like
even you know people investing or any
leverage in life when it's in your favor
it's doing this wonderful thing when
it's going against you it is it's making
your life miserable and I think that's
my best way of summing up I'm sorry I'm
not saying it correctly but I say
passions that's my way of summing up the
passion people it's like leverage so go
in as an ally kill isn't going it as a
friend in the experience is exceptional
but if you're on the other side as
history is shown you just have to poke
into the books a little but the Gateway
of the Indian subcontinent I mean what a
place right they've seen their war
they've seen their blood and I don't
know how that blood comes out I mean how
the hospitality comes out of all that
conflict and it's so sweet but it is
that's what's crazy you usually think of
someone's if a people have endured so
much battle and warfare that they're
gonna be hardened like very much
hardened right because an outsider
you know biologically you think is a
threat like the guy that looks different
or acts different from a different tribe
and that's usually been the guy
attacking you well
how they do it but they're not like that
they're super cool okay thank you for
the super chat I'm gonna answer your
question here love your first log in
peshawar please do more vlogs in
peshawar press Jane and passions Pashtun
are the same okay cool yeah Peshawar I
only had what I have two days there so I
shot two videos I would love to return
to that part of the country I would love
to get more into the countryside there
that is that is it definitely on the
radar when I get back there I will I
will dig into that part of the country
more for sure
cries great great questions I love it
you know what I love about all of you is
this audience is cool
like I mean it's YouTube so YouTube is
the cesspool of the planet for bad
comments you know you can see it what I
did the video on Indian Pakistan right
you're gonna get the most traumatized
people and this isn't any judgement it's
just how it works
politics is what brings out that rage
and what not and you're gonna you know
get the f fuse and this and that right
that's like that's how the platform
works with that said man I've got so
many cool people you guys like really
cool interesting thought-provoking
questions that have led me down the
rabbit hole of Google and and trying to
learn more so I really appreciate that
because that's I don't think it's
totally normal on on YouTube maybe it's
just type of content you know travel
content that does it but I'm very
grateful for that okay okay tons of
great questions I'm gonna try not to
repeat myself this live stream like no
guarantees but I'm gonna try my hardest
okay comparison between Pakistan and
Iran are these are their similarities
and differences this is Guzman Guzman
good question yes yeah for sure so I did
a video on Pakistan India you could
definitely I could definitely do one on
Pakistan in Iran
I'll give you a few
few basic similarities and differences
super hospitable Thank You guys super
chats appreciate that I'm gonna get to
this super hospitable very regionalised
different people I mean you can it's so
cool this part of the world because you
have okc saying indian pakistan you have
punjab e people and that that's in both
countries well in Balochistan you have
that region spills into both countries
to right say yeah there's so much common
ground
cool people good food very
misrepresented in the i mean these are
like didn't GW call these george w bush
call these the axis of evil was pakistan
in there i know Iran was so they're very
misrepresented a lot of heart a lot of
soul a lot of passion religion huh
i would say that's a tough one okay the
the government in Iran is is a theocracy
so that's different right but it really
depends on the person of the region I
would say is like as far as the the
levels of religion go and then they're
like both countries have their young
really well educated really worldly like
hipster populations in the cities that I
that I met for sure okay how do i ali
ali nine nine eight okay let me hit one
of these chats first one second delhi
okay youtuber makes haters get a
platform but good people too
yeah for sure LLB you're one of them and
yeah in the audience i have you guys are
fantastic thank you who is this this is
Neha great work Peter Newhall thank you
and thanks for supporting the channel
that's it's very cool guys cuz Facebook
the monetize my whole series they
absolutely it's a it's like mafia over
there they actually you know I don't
worry about the police don't like say
sorry or anything that's it's all par
for the course is how this stuff works
but to monetize the
whole series that did really well on
Facebook too so that's why I like
YouTube better okay okay questions
questions so many good questions okay
Jay thank you for the super chat really
enjoy your experiences what places will
you visit that you missed out on if you
visit it again okay I want to go to Swat
Valley I want to go to scar do I'd like
to just poke into those mountain regions
a little bit more like to explore more
of the KPK in the northwest kurachi I
could do more videos in for sure look
she's I can I could spend months there
really it's it's a very ripe country as
a video maker let's just say that if you
want to dig into it as you guys know or
if you see my content I'm not in for
hitting the big sites and the monuments
and that sort of stuff other people can
do that better than me what I want to
get is the ground level the color on the
streets the color and the people I could
stand has tons of that I mean the whole
region really like Iran Iran was the
first big series I did as a youtuber
that blew my mind that was amazing India
India's its own universe it's like I've
never felt as alive as a person as in
India because all your senses are so
clobbered like smell taste sound sights
everything just everyday like a baseball
bat over your head which is amazing like
it's it's just in a live place I'd say
Pakistan and Iran would be I'm trying to
think of other countries where I felt so
embraced let's say I'm probably missing
a country or two out but I'd say though
those two countries are at the top for
that for sure
any mark I think his name was Mark any
visit and he plans to visit Toronto no
no plans to visit Toronto reason being
is I live in Ukraine I
can't leave the country right now or I
won't be able to get back so the content
is looking like this guys I have a video
Sunday coming out the best of Pakistan I
think you'll like it because I do like a
very condensed version of the trip with
some commentary let's say then I have a
whole u.s. series I'm starting to I'm
gonna put out next week I think you guys
will like that because I get a lot of
people you know I've always done work in
the world never in my own country a lot
of people ask me about the US a lot of
people are just have no clue about it
really like I think it's Hollywood
movies and they're gonna go to Hollywood
Boulevard and meet bad Brad Pitt
you know walking down the street that
sort of thing no it's not like that
it's a very diverse diverse mixed-up
place and I'm gonna touch on some of
that I went with my girlfriend at the
time now she's my wife I think it's
gonna be like a five or six part series
and guys I'm gonna touch just like in
Pakistan or the other work I do I'm
gonna touch on the you know like some of
the opulent wealth but I'm really gonna
show you like the pain points to I
there's this one part in San Francisco
you won't believe exist there my wife
had her jaw dropped you'll see it in the
video she's just she's never seen
anything like it
and I guarantee if you're from Pakistan
India Iran Ukraine Europe wherever you
don't have it and what I'm gonna show
you is just this part of San Francisco
Cisco where it's not wealthy and
societies falling apart a little bit
I'll hit on all things so I got that
coming up and then I'll be having
Ukraine work coming up because I'm in
Ukraine it's a foreign country and I
have plenty of videos to shoot here some
interesting stories and that's it for
the future who knows where we're at
right like would travel I really don't
feel like getting on a plane and going
into a country and getting close to
people I think it's a bit disrespectful
at this point in time like my work is
all about connecting with the people so
coming up with a camera really close
I'm gonna wait a little bit on that see
where we're at I think the question was
like ten hours ago by Jay will I visit
Pakistan again and and yes I will
thoughts about Islamabad
okay Islamabad is the city that most
foreigners would not think exists in
Pakistan wide boulevards a lot of new
buildings a lot of space I look at it as
a green Phoenix Arizona and I'm probably
offending some people but check it out
here's why
wide wide roads new gas stations car
culture no real buzzing hum of a center
like the other big Pakistani cities it's
not that you know if I was to live in
Pakistan
I would probably live in Islamabad just
because at this point my life I want a
little more quiet but if I was younger
it's not the place like law or Karachi
and a Peshawar are way more active and
lively I would say okay the food fight
is the food of Pakistan was it different
from India yes and no I talked about
this earlier you have the region's right
so the region's the borders native
English speakers or people that speak
well most of you guys will understand
this the borders bleed and I don't mean
like blood I mean like they come
together and so if when you're in Punjab
or spoon job food on the Indian side
Punjab food on the Pakistani side so in
that region yeah but if you go to
Peshawar and Kerala India totally
different food like completely different
cuisines all right
hid job mandatory in Saudi like Iran no
it's not that was a surprise to me
Nestor on I believe I suppose a
pronounced your name great questions so
she's asking about the hijab and Iran
and Saudi what I went into Saudi I was I
was surprised I was shocked that you
know some women could have their head
completely out in the open no hijab no
haired covering and I was blown away I
thought this okay
I was thinking Saudi Arabia is the most
conservative country on the planet and
if anywhere they're gonna be you know
restricted more and it was not the case
now that depends regionally to like if
you go at the Jeddah it's much more
liberal if you go to the countryside
it's gonna be more conservative Riyadh
is opening up a lot so I've heard in
recent years depends the family or in or
a lot of things but the state in the
places most of the places that I went is
not it's not my law we're in Iran it's
by law Iran you know you see oh there's
this Craig I wish I could show you my
phone what's on my phone
this group of skater chicks that I
follow in Iran they're young teenagers
or all skaters I did a video on them
actually on my YouTube channel and they
you know they press the boundaries right
in Iran some some woman have their head
scarfs like hanging here right
they're just rebelling and in some days
I believe it was Wednesday's they were
having days where they're taking him off
completely I don't know if that's still
going on but the skater scene there's a
woman women's skateboarding scene there
and a lot of them have like I was
shooting the video and they didn't have
him on you know as I go she I can't I
can't make a video like this I don't
want to get anyone in trouble and so one
girl puts on her her hat and it says HOF
with American I don't want to leave and
the other girls hanging something way
off the back and so it's interesting to
see
how that plays out in both countries for
sure okay what's my what are my feelings
about family culture and Pakistan okay
from what I saw it looks like a very
cohesive society with that said I'm sure
there's all sorts of family trauma and
abusive families and every type of
family just like everywhere in the world
but I like it seem like the unit was
overall the unit was pretty pretty
strong I would say okay guys questions
tons of them I'm gonna try not to repeat
myself here oh here's one I got a ton of
people emailed me what's my favorite
part of Pakistan don't have one
I like diversity I like being shocked
and surprised
so Lahore is a must-see for sure I think
yeah can't go to the country and not see
Lahore Hunza is a must-see for me
because again it's one of those
surprises you're up and Hunza there's a
guy with red haired blue eyes and the
old men are speaking perfect English and
you're scratching your head saying well
I'm looking on a map here I'm your
Afghanistan China and and and what else
yeah Afghanistan and China in India way
from everything as far as like any
population densities and there's the
best literacy rate as far as you know
older English speakers go I've seen
outside of a native English speaking
country so you got to see that Hansa and
the beauty the sheer beauty the culture
is amazing Peshawar I mean the trip I
did maybe I was lucky maybe I got I knew
some of what I was getting into as far
as the diversity but you never know
until you go totally different Karachi
got to see that if you just want to see
sheer madness I mean the city lives on
the edge it is on it's like on the
knife's edge
and that's what makes it exciting you
can't be bored in Karachi I guess if
you're sitting in front of a screen and
not leaving your house you might get
irritated with crotchy but you can't get
bored there it's it's it's fired up
it doesn't sleep it's loud it's a beast
and Islamabad
I mean Islamabad didn't Wow me
it wasn't like wow Islamabad or here's a
nice place so I think that balances it
out though if you see the madness of
Karachi and then go to Islamabad well
that's that's pretty cool
mixed up so I don't have a favorite
place I put all these places in my
playlist below here ten videos all these
different places could I've seen more in
the time I made these videos no no and
if I want to sleep no but there's a lot
to go back to you for sure
what is the purpose of my life that's a
good question I like it
philosophical well I think the purpose
of your life is to find purpose in your
life and that's very much subjective to
who you are as a person it could be
raising kids
it could be building a business it could
be driving a Ferrari I don't know
everyone's different right but I think
it's actually going for what gives you
purpose so the purpose in my life is
making this content I feel I'm not
getting rich I'm not making any money
right now barely I'm covering my cost of
doing it and I've never been happier
doing what I'm doing so that's when I
know I'm in the right place I would say
so if you're asking me for for advice
whatever makes I think also what you
gravitate towards when there's no one
mana monitoring you which means like no
job no outside folk you know elements
like what are you looking at online what
are you picking up and read
what what grabs your attention and I
think if you can put your attention in
those places then you're getting close
to the purpose of life
now feds beer or cocaine and then you
might want to reconsider but if these
are healthy things I think that's that's
what it's about
Allisyn thing the purpose of life
changes I don't have kids and I think
when I do it might all change right like
my focus will change to some degree
so good question I like it ok ok a deal
we are grateful grateful for depicting
our culture a positive image of Pakistan
despite all the issues our countrymen
are facing thanks and welcome brother
thank you brother a deal I don't know if
this is the 'deal I met in Lahore if it
is you are amazing you showed me the
city like like no other
I don't think any other person has that
knowledge of the old city like you but
yeah I mean it's just it's a good it's a
good I'm not a question it's a statement
but I would like to if you dig into it
quite often it's the complexities in the
history of a place which makes it what
it is obviously you know quite often
that's what it does and so what's
beautiful about Pakistan came from a lot
of turbulence - right like a lot of a
lot of hardships and I'm not saying
that's a good thing and I'm not saying
great like nobody wants to be
uncomfortable or nobody wants conflict
but the most peaceful stable place ok
Switzerland used to live there for a
little bit probably the last country I'd
make a video on it's just not that
interesting it's a beautiful country on
paper it's got everything going for it
it's probably the best place to live on
paper but is it is it gonna give you
what Pakistan gives you no not at all
like not even close so
yeah I know I understand the I don't
understand like you do if you're if
you've lived through it I can no one can
never understand you know if they don't
live through it but those histories are
what make places the way they are for
good and for bad right
I live in Ukraine the history here is
quite turbulent and that that brings out
a lot of cool things about the culture
it also brings out a lot of bad things
but it is what it is right
okay someone asked me for some humor I
missed that one lb lb I feel like I feel
like you um did my mom pay you to give
me all this money what's going on I like
it though thank you I appreciate it okay
did I have any alcohol
Jawad did I have any alcohol and
Pakistan you asked that roughly ten
times I got it I did not I don't drink
anymore I quit five years ago four or
five years ago so I like a culture that
isn't all about I'll be is my mom there
we go no no I like a culture that isn't
revolved around alcohol I've had plenty
of party days in my time I have no
regrets it was fun but I've I've quit
completely by accident that's a whole
nother story so when I when I was in
Pakistan it'sit's great I like that
people get together around other things
that are now gone now if you drink
alcohol you can get it there if you're a
Christian it's legal I believe it's
legal to buy if you're a Christian there
are places to get it and if you want to
go to nice hotels it's there and if you
want to mad crazy double horns of a
night life it's there I have I follow
this heavy metal band from Lahore they
seem to rock it pretty hard
haven't been to Goa India yeah I went to
go India like five years ago
my favorite place I like India go is
probably my least favorite in India and
I only went to like the tour spot there
I know it's beautiful there's a lot to
see I just wasn't into like the over
tourism in the in the it was like
Russian and Israeli mobs working with
each other it seemed like it's just
tight maybe it was my experience a lot
of travel is who you run into what
happens during that time goal wasn't my
favorite Nydia I went up to what is it
called mone know starts with an M up in
the mountains there in the western god
so that was fantastic
that was amazing Kerala was amazing okay
you're proud of me for not smoking and
drinking thank you
yeah smoking I never understood I just
didn't like the taste of it and drinking
I did plenty of that and it was a lot of
fun but uh I hit like I'm 42 now I hit I
think it was 30 yamuna rlb you're right
Munnar you're right that's the place in
India that I loved I hit 37 I think it
was and I had like to be I'd be hungover
after two beers was crazy something
happened in my metabolism where he was
just destroying me no judgment against
drinking everyone's got their thing
I'm much better without it and you never
know okay I never knew I was yeah I hate
to even say it was I an alcoholic or not
I didn't drink every day but you never
know until you stop like how much you
rely on it and every time I was you know
coming meeting up with friends or like
traveling or something and getting to
the end of a interesting day I'd always
go to it'd be like this crutch and I
realized it was a crutch only when I was
out of it my dad was an alcoholic - he
he he went clean though he had to do
hardcore rehab though I didn't have to
do that thank God
Oh beautiful painting thank you yeah
that's a Ukrainian artist that did that
I love it
I like surrealism and it's there's so
there are some really good are
here did I see Taliban and Pakistan no
and I met ya in the hoods of video I
asked the guy I was hanging out with
fighting the same question he's like
I've never seen Taliban in my life so
super chat super chat the name of the
heavy metal band I follow oh man it's on
my phone and my phone is what I'm making
the video out of hit me up on contact at
Peter Santaniello calm with that
question and I'll get you the name of
that metal band these guys are good I
wish I knew them when I was there
because I would have made a video with
them
they are amazing good underground metal
everyone's got a little place for that
did I visit Chernobyl I've been in
Chernobyl I was there like three years
ago and I might go back there because I
have a u.s. series I'm doing then I got
to do a bunch of Ukrainian videos I got
a bunch of ideas and I I thought
Chernobyl was overplayed like so many
people went there and made videos I was
like I don't want to do it too but I
might go back since there are really no
foreigners in the country now it's
probably pretty empty out their next
destination Saad so American series
coming out next week and then it will be
Ukraine I live in Ukraine and I will be
doing a bunch of videos here for me it's
still interesting because it's the
abroad and I can get in all sorts of
adventures and Ukraine is a quirky
interesting lively country so there's
plenty to get in this country after that
I was actually I was supposed to be in
Lebanon and Syria so on the list videos
I really want to make Lebanon Syria I
was in Syria in 2008 loved the country
Damascus as of this moment is stabled
and travel and you know I do my due
diligence beforehand but I really want
to go back there and then Palestine now
I've been to parts of the West Bank
before that was super interesting
I would like to do sort of a
palestine-israel thing so a lot of
Middle Eastern stuff I just get pulled
back into the Middle East because that's
where I
I just find it the most interesting the
world without the Middle East would
would be like missing so much so much
color so I mean it's look at the history
right there's there been flare-ups
massive flare-ups throughout history but
I just I love the Middle East and that's
such a blanket term like people that I
haven't traveled to the Middle East are
you going to the Middle East like it's
one country like oh we're going to
Africa well okay what's half Riga 56
countries or something like that or 52
Middle East is I think 16 countries are
considered the Middle East could be
wrong on that but they're all so
different right and it's such a
misrepresented region there's a lot to
it so I'll be back in that region Egypt
Mohammed Egypt that many Egypt twice
loved Egypt the only reservation I have
about Egypt going back there now is I've
been there twice like my last Indian
video it wasn't so much of a surprise to
me because I had been India twice before
[Music]
so like when I walked into Pakistan it
was all new I was like fresh off the
boat that was everything was a surprise
in Egypt
I sort of know how it works to some
degree I do have to return there though
Cairo is one of the great Arab cities
the biggest city in Africa I think it's
bigger than Lagos and a lot to get so
Malaysia been in Malaysia lenka we love
that I used to live in Bangkok Thailand
in my mid-20s and I'd go down to
Malaysia I didn't ever went to KL but
like how a nice place Turkish called
hurt did I see more Turkish culture in
Pakistan than around
I don't think so I don't think so
yeah and if I went you to breeze in Iran
I know that's very Turkish feeling from
what I've heard okay
create questions guys they're ripping
through on the phone so if you're seeing
the top of my head bear with me I get a
look at my computer did I visit Swat
Valley no that's definitely on the list
for sure
I wish I could have gone there I really
wanted to go to swat I'm very humble my
wife might not agree with you sometimes
I can be loud and brash but I try to
make this content as I see it and if it
comes across as humble then cool hope I
get 1 million subscribers lb thanks for
the donation again you're you're on fire
me too me too
I honestly guys just feel like I got my
foundation with this because I'm going
full-time though honestly the first
videos I did had no clue what I was
doing I know clearly what I was doing up
until not that long ago to be honest so
now I know if I go to another country
what my format is how I got to do it how
I need to present the video better what
you guys are looking for more which is
that like on-the-ground interaction the
stuff that I actually like doing the
best and less like produce stuff like my
first videos where like I got to go to
this place and get every sight in every
shot and then make a narrative and then
try to compose it in the best way I
turned into a nightmare and then I
realized [ __ ] I can just you know think
of like finding the rappers in Karachi
and that's a story and you as the viewer
know what I'm going for and it's much
simpler I'm not showing all the Karachi
in that video though I'm showing a story
and now I'm just into showing these
stories which is what people want
actually so yeah million subscribers I
I'm going for I'm going for I have 200
thousand now thank you guys
for that and got a long way to go visit
Denmark
I was just s car I just got off the
phone or what's half of the good buddy
of mine who lives in he's from Denmark
lives in Columbia actually Denmark is a
mystery to me it is so expensive you get
a like a hamburger for 25 let's begin
dollars twenty five dollars
taxes are through the roof people make
good money but everyone has huge
household debt but there's like no
anxiety in in the culture it's weird you
go to San Francisco and it's expensive
and people are making good money but
there's so much anxiety there's so much
fear of missing out there's so much [ __ ]
if I lose my job I'm I'm I'm all over
type mentality we're in Denmark it's
just I don't get it I still don't
understand that country to be honest
it's a nice place okay lb please tell
all the chatters to love not hate love
don't hate hate is pain we all have it
and it's just how do you channel it
howdy Channel I've done a lot of work
and I have a lot more work to do
politics is a good way to channel pain
it's an easy one if I hear some anti
Trump rhetoric I sort of like tune into
it and I got a catch stop myself okay
why am i why am I getting fuel off this
like a parasite okay it's touching on
this pain body okay why why why and then
you can usually steer it back to some
childhood experience or some family
issue or some whatever and then it's
just like that's the sign you got to go
in and do the work it's easy to dump
rage on YouTube that's that's easy and I
feel bad for people that do it I can't
imagine getting on YouTube and just like
even if I don't like someone's content
taking the time to tell them how much
they suck or something it's just a
bizarre I don't take it personally in
the beginning you have to you're like
whoa what's what's this and then you
realize this person doesn't know me
and this is their issue every once in a
while it still gets me though if I'm in
the wrong mood you know sleep-deprived
or something and I get someone ripping
in on me I'll take it you know every
once in while I'm human it happens right
but for the most part you you get a
thick skin after a while if you if you
don't have it then this platform is
probably not the place to be putting
your videos up on it okay questions
questions questions so many cool
questions crotch your Mumbai
that's like apples and oranges two
different universes stupid people should
not have an internet connection says lb
I agree okay postcard stamps that's the
name I'm seeing thank you for the super
chat appreciate it
do you miss some countries like you miss
people good question well a country is
always the product of its people right
so I think they go hand in hand
I miss Iran a lot it's been a while it
was it's been like two years that's a
place I really miss and it's I just
think of the people right and the
experiences so you'll you'll have me
thinking about this one
I look at a country the best thing about
a country like I'm not going to say go
to Austria for the most amazing
experiences with the people Austria is a
beautiful place there are great people
there I know people in Austria it's
amazing but they not gonna care that
you're there than it like if you go to
Pakistan or Iran it's not it's not the
same experience so do I like the country
Austria yeah it's beautiful I mean
that's it's almost like you have
different clothes like you wear for
different events different outings so if
I was to go with my wife we're going to
go for
a week roadtrip I'd be really pumped to
go to Austria and just cruise and like
be a nice nature and clean air and all
that stuff
but if I was gonna go for a week in
Pakistan I'd almost rather I would take
her she would love Hunza she would not
like the big chaotic city she just
wanted she doesn't like all that noise
and chaos and I'd rather just be on the
ground meeting people so good question I
like it did I visit every state in India
I think missed all that question
twenty-nine states in India no I haven't
I've been in any of three times I've
seen all the ways far south is Kerala
for coaching I've gone as far north as
Emirates are but I didn't get into the
Himalayas I went to Dehradun I didn't
get to the east side of the country I've
been to Bangalore and my sort of Mysore
was cool Mysore is a very cool city a
very cool vibe there I liked it the
Western got mountains India is just its
own universe its own planet and that's
another really misunderstood place in
making the last video I made I just
couldn't believe that it was just a
crazy stat and sure most Indians and
Pakistanis know this but there are
almost as many Muslims in India as in
Pakistan how crazy is that that's just
that stop me just thinking about that in
itself India you can't put a label I
mean really no country you can put a
label on labels are easy labels define
things labels you know make things black
and white right and wrong all that stuff
but if you really want to poke into a
place you know a massive country like
India it's everything and I say the same
for the states I'm doing my series right
now for those that you don't know I'll
be posting next week I I mix I wasn't
gonna do this one honestly we shot this
last fall my wife and I I was like yeah
maybe this isn't that interesting and
from my perspective going to all the
places I
when talking about the things that I've
I've known forever there so it's not
that interesting and then I've had a lot
of my audience a lot of my audience is
foreign and they're asking me questions
about the States and they're saying
things about the states that have you
know make no sense just because they
haven't been there like before Pakistan
I don't if you don't go to a place how
do you know about it and so then I look
through the footage now there's some
good stuff in here
and so I'm editing right now it's gonna
be a five six part series on the States
but actually it's just Northern
California but my point being is this is
an interesting thing I thought it today
I could feel more how do i word this I
could feel more culturally like
connected to a hipster bar in Islamabad
then I could in some regions in my own
country like I would feel more out of
place and say some regions that I would
love it like I love feeling out of place
I think that's exciting that's
interesting it's a challenge but there
are there are places in America where I
have less in common with people than if
I was in say some some cafe in Islamabad
and that's where it gets really
interesting right when you you know and
discovering my own country I have to I'm
gonna do a lot of I have a lot of video
ideas for the States I almost want to do
like an inside America Edition go to the
deep south and go to the Northeast where
I grew up and go to you know the west
where I've lived my whole adult life and
show you guys like contrasting and
comparing in all the weirdness that
unless you went you'd have no clue
exists can pakis Pakistanis say the N
word don't say the N word the N word is
like the worst in America is a white guy
okay Black's can say it in their rap
tunes and do each other right that's
that's considered okay but as a white
guy you don't say the n-word
you just can't go there I don't suggest
he isn't it
she'll be UK or England have I visited
yes I've been to the UK many times and I
would like to you know some interesting
ideas down the road guys would be like
showing you know Pakistanis and Indians
in London or in New York or something
like that like seeing the people from
these countries I've been to in living
in the West I think those would be some
there would be some interesting stories
in there okay guys few more questions so
many good ones I really appreciate it I
really appreciate the engagement the
interest I enjoy doing this even though
it's weird I'm talking into a lens but
it's it's cool that we can do this it's
cool the technology's here where is the
best country okay yup
dope said this the best country what's
the best food what's the best movie
who's the best woman it's like it's all
the pen it's all subjectivity it depends
who what's the best country for me now
might not be the best country for me in
ten years and you can say that for
everything so there's no the best I look
at places like like a pie graph right
and say you take ten categories like you
know ecology economy diversity whatever
right and where you're at in your life
and what you value there are going to be
places that way out better than others
so what will break me from Ukraine is
just the the ecology like just the I
love this country in many ways but I
look I'm in a city that's Kiva's roughly
4 million people they project it in 10
years to be 7.5 million
and you have a government that does not
a city planning that's not really
planning and a lot of days the air is
bad here and it's only gonna get worse
and they're only gonna be more cars on a
limited amount of roads and I don't see
the conditions getting better for the
long run because the ecology environment
is not a priority with this with this
this government that's for sure so that
to me has become more important now air
quality has become more important two
years ago I didn't think about air
quality ever I had never even considered
it and now I've started to notice it and
now I've looked into and research like
what it does to your health and where do
I want to bring kids up in bad air
quality now now today it's good air
quality and I'm not saying it's bad here
all the time but my point is the best
man it's it's like like when people ask
you know what should I do
for a career or whatever nobody can give
you that information right nobody can
you have to go down the road figuring it
out and doing the hard work look I'm 42
and I'm just figuring this out
trust me it's taken a lot of battles a
lot of metaphorically banging my head on
the wall like what am i doing how do I
do this I was honestly a couple years
ago looking to set up and a sales team
okay and there is nothing wrong with
that but it's just my heart wasn't in it
I thought about you know a sales team
here in Ukraine for you know servicing
Western businesses and then I thought
about okay I could see how this could
make good money
I'd like that component of it I like
setting up systems and I like business
okay cool but then I'm like what's the
day-in day-out and they're spending
nights up all night I'll probably burn
out of it it's not really my passion and
back to the drawing board
so that whole best thing is like depends
who you are what you want favorite
favorite food in Pakistan oh here's
something I really like I'm in Lahore
there was I don't know what it's called
there was this sweet dish that you put
on bread that's sweet like milky stuff
you put on bread that was amazing
never had anything like that and also in
Karachi there was this karate no it
wasn't chicken karahi it was uh
something else really good like egg
chicken dish loved it
why is the u.s. losing hospitality rate
don't totally understand your question I
think you mean why is it losing its
level of hospitality like friendliness I
don't know I am again the u.s. is very
mixed up and it very much depends where
you live
where I grew up in Vermont we didn't
have a key for our door we never locked
our house I couldn't even see the
neighbor's house I grew up in the
countryside like we would go into a
store in the winter it was so cold in
the winters my mom would leave the car
running and we go into the store and
come back so that's one reality and then
you got South Side Chicago where it's
hard core from what I've heard I'd like
to do some videos there actually so
hospitality there are places that are
super hospitable and there are places
that aren't that's all I can say
I think the Midwest probably has some of
the nicest people I wouldn't want to
live there but it probably has some of
the nicest people like less anxiety less
stress like if you're in Kansas in some
small town I'm sure people if you're
cool they're very cool and like willing
to help and be hospitable I think it
really depends it really depends where
you're at and how you approach things I
think the u.s. can be a very hospitable
country I think one of the pros is
people have no problem talking with
strangers like just opening up a
dialogue with someone you don't know I
do miss that about it I think it's one
of the pluses of the country of the
culture for sure funny memories for my
travels well how many people will get oh
you still got people watching um let me
think about that there they're a bunch
of stories trying to think funny all
right I'll come back to that the best
comments of my Pakistani videos you know
what the comments I like look when
someone leaves like you know I touched
them in some way or like it brought out
some good feeling in them and they're
sharing that that's cool that's what I'm
like I know I'm doing something right
it's it's effective those are the
comments I mean I like all the comments
and I can't as you know someone who
gives comments on YouTube all the time
most of my comments are not emotional
okay Hasan I'm gonna get to your
question which Indian caste do you
assume hates Pakistan the most look I
don't know the castes like how they're
labeled I know the basics like what the
untouchables and this and this whatnot
but Gandhi so you know outlawed that
right but it still exists I don't think
it's a caste I think it's a mindset if
someone is angry at life they need to
vent look if you're if you haven't
resolved some [ __ ] in your life and that
rage does not go away and you need to
put it direct it somewhere there's
nowhere better than a political enemy
that's how this stuff works that's how
the world runs unfortunately right I
honestly think part of the reason the
u.s. went to Iraq part of it
other than to make you know Dick Cheney
pushing it and trying to make a lot of
money off it was the fact that George W
Bush wanted to get back at Saddam
Hussein for trying to kill his father
I think it's that primal I think it's
that simple actually so I think that's
part of the reason so as far as a cast
hating Pakistanis look you can have the
janitor right that is the coolest guy
he's fine with his life he's not making
much money he's not doing so-called the
you know exotic work or anything but he
can be totally fine with his life and he
would never leave any negative anything
anywhere because it's not in him or you
can have the wealthiest guy that you
know or you can op Donald Trump right
he's an angry person he has to vent he
has to shame and label and alienate and
that's just in his makeup he's dealing
with a lot of pain so I don't think as
anything deal with cast it's personality
type good or bad people everywhere that
one went by me okay here we are good and
padded people everywhere mr. Peter there
any advice
a Pakistani nation from the eye of a
foreigner I hope you can mention it okay
if you want constructive advice and I
this is not my position as an outsider
to look into a country and tell them how
they should do things it so that's I'm
gonna preface it like that that's not
that's not my right but if you're asking
what you're asking about advice the
trash like clean up that trash and I get
it governments are not doing a good job
especially in Karachi I mean they're
they're left to their own I think a lot
of those neighborhoods I don't think the
municipalities are doing much it still
doesn't mean you should burn your
plastic bags right so that's all
education that's if your dad does it
you're gonna do it right so it's
education so education in those things
we need it everywhere it's not
Pakistan anything either world peace
will come to people like me
thank you infinite being I appreciate
the contribution I think it will come to
people like you you just sound like
you're I've never even said world peace
because you're you're probably a better
person than me for saying that look
everything has a frequency right so how
I affect people look you ever know when
you're on you're hanging out with
someone right and how do you feel
afterwards is it is it excite you or are
you feeling better like it bring you up
why were they like what are you doing
that for why are you doing that with
your life they're nagging on you trying
to bring you down maybe you're trying
something new and they're they're
doubting you and you feel like [ __ ]
afterwards that's what it all is right
so if I feel like [ __ ] afterwards then
I'm gonna make those around me feel and
it just brings down the frequency right
so people like I'm sorry your name flew
by me infinite being people like you
that bring it up or what I'm trying to
do I you know what can I do I'm not
gonna try to get into politics and you
know or get into the face of politicians
and tell them how it should be I don't
think that method is actually is
powerful is doing something like this
where you can I hope you guys get
something positive out of this or my
videos and then that brings frequency up
it at a little a little you know metric
and then that all multiplies right and
no matter what it is listen to like
listening to content listening to
podcasts do they make you feel better
afterwards or worse or like what you're
watching on TV
I will admit I just out of curiosity I
go to CNN and Fox both I think they're
both out of their mind
both those networks for the most part
like what you see thank you thank you
Akhil I'm gonna get your your question
thank you for the donation
both those networks are
out of their mind they're just looking
for clicks they don't they don't care
how the world is gonna be you know they
they don't they're not trying to do like
make the world a better place try to
make money these are businesses right
but I do go to them because they touch
on our pain bodies they touch on like
80% of our attention goes to the
negative that's why when I did a video
in Saudi Arabia I didn't even know at
the time I had no idea this was a bad
thing it was my first day there I met
this guy he was he had a girlfriend he
said it I met him in this food court you
know in a shopping mall what interesting
I didn't think that existed here it's my
first day I don't even know I put that
in the video
I have pissed a lot of people off hey
I'm not I'm not there's no judgment I'm
not saying what's right or wrong with my
what I'm showing it's like that's what I
saw that's what I'm showing my audience
right
and I didn't think it was that line I
didn't think anything wrong with it but
because it hit on a negative for so many
people that's my most popular video like
because of that encounter like the I'd
like to think there's a lot more great
stuff in that video but it's only
because of that that it you know was
shared and went so far everywhere right
so the negativity is what gets attention
if I wanted to be probably hated more
and get more attention I could dive in
and hit some pain on the politics of
places and be more of an ass but it's
just not what I want to do or who I want
to be okay a keel from from love from
India bro like your videos how many
girls you dated in your life asking
casually good question girlfriends like
legitimate solid girlfriends I don't
know I don't know if my wife's watching
this either but hey it's all open it's
all transparency I would say like five
or six maybe
just got married and I'm 42 so I've been
around a little bit like I'm not 21
Thank You Dennis appreciate the donation
do you have a question my last
livestream I didn't I didn't know you
had to answer lives my second one you
know you had to answer the the super
chats which makes sense these are people
paying and like I'm gonna try my best to
answer every one but the super Chad's
definitely lb says flings I think you
may need account maybe I'll be maybe
you're onto something okay would you
consider asking the tough questions in
the future like race relations in
America Hindu Muslim conflict in India
Palestine and Israel issue and feelings
on Muslims and vice-versa
yeah yeah this is um this is something I
I struggle with in my content so check
it out when I make a video I'm going in
I have hours of video and I have to
condense it down to save 20 minutes so
it's it's watchable and what do I leave
in what do I leave out the overall goal
the overall goal for all of this content
is to say I'm gonna speak selfishly
because I'm American hey American
speaking to myself like no it's not all
that bad out there actually no you can
go to Istanbul I know ruin and Trump
don't get along and the politics sucks
and whatever but you're gonna be fine
when you go there and I have friends who
are educated people in the sense that
they went to good universities they're
smart they read a lot like I can't go to
Istanbul why how the relations are too
bad I just that's what moves me on all
of this stuff so I don't want to make
content that scares people from the
world that's that's the whole point like
I want I want to inspire people
because I feel like the majority scares
you know everyone from going somewhere
if you watch CNN or Fox like why would
you go anywhere it looks terrible out
there so as far as race relations and
getting deep into the deeper issues yes
I mean that's where my interests are in
on my private time and in my
conversations I'm always going there how
do I make it in a way where I'm just not
you know firing up a lot of hate and you
know I'm not a journalist I'm not
pretending I'm not really I'm not a
journalist I don't really consider
myself a travel vlogger just to show
myself traveling the world I've done
that I've done that you know for a long
time I there's a purpose behind it and
I'm not looking down on anyone's content
or how they are there approaches but I'm
not saying I have a better way of doing
what I'm saying is I mean I'm not really
the vlogger don't you know I'm not 25
and want to show you the sandwich I'm
eating on the streets I want to get into
some of the some of the deeper cultural
context sort of somewhere in the middle
yeah
it's a tough tough balance but I do want
to get into Palestine I feel like that
place is just not getting much of a
voice I want to get into Gaza this is
high up on the list Syria I just feel I
feel so it's just a misrepresented place
I feel like a real desire to get pulled
into there go back so I didn't really
answer your question I do need to poke
into a little more but in a
light-hearted way right Oh a lenient
people is my wife and Pakistan I think
that's what you said sorry these are
cruising through my wife is here in
Ukraine she looks she's she considers
herself an introvert and
even though she's sociable and I can
talk with anyone just fine but she
doesn't like all the noise and the like
the craziness that I like I I find that
Paul stimulating I love it
that's not her thing so she was not
interested in Pakistan but when she saw
the Hunza Valley video then she was like
all right I want to go there so I would
love to take her I would love to take
her to the mountains in Pakistan one day
okay
suggestions of Pakistan to bring in more
tourists Denise thanks again and let me
know if you got a question here I think
don't pretend don't don't try to be
something or not
and I'm not saying anyone was but don't
make your tourism campaigns about
shopping malls and saying Islamabad is
paradise on earth you can do that but I
don't think that's why people are gonna
want to go to Pakistan look if you want
the most beautiful nature that's that's
pristine with no horns no bumps in the
road all the grass is manicured
perfectly you're not going to Pakistan
you're going to Switzerland it's just
the reality
so what Pakistan has is just such a deep
and rich culture and it's almost hard to
call it one country right
it's almost many countries in one so I
promote that you know high up in Hunza
these guys I call it the it was called
the University of Lahore it was a joke
it was all these old men hanging out
playing games singing it was just so
real like that's the stuff you don't
want to lose that's the stuff that
people find interesting I think I think
if someone goes to pack
ten from America or say from Western
Europe they're gonna be more adventurous
more open-minded because look they're
gonna have to go against some
conditioning they're gonna have to go
against their friends saying why are you
going there it's not gonna be a good
response it's the reality hey mom I'm
going to Pakistan she's not gonna be
excited ninety-five percent of the time
my mom was cool she was like yeah she
she's used to me but the common
narrative for the average person it's
it's unfortunate but this is the reality
that's why I'm making content this is
why other people make content and this
is why I think the narrative will change
but go for what's cool about you guys
and that that's just that hospitality
that's that diversity that's that it's
the stuff you know what people want is
what they don't have so don't don't show
off the shopping malls because they have
that in the buy is gonna be better for
shopping anyway so why would anyone go
to Pakistan for that and clean up the
trash the trash is individuals aren't
going to be it has to be at a government
initiative it has to come from the top
it has to be like laced into the
education look Rwanda did it okay it's a
small country
my place is pristine like very clean it
can be done but I think that
unfortunately that takes away sometimes
of the look I don't really care I'm not
it's not it's it's an afterthought when
I'm there but I think it would probably
push some people away any plans to visit
Quetta I would like to I would like to
if you have any ideas about Quetta
please email me contact at Peter
Santaniello comm love to learn more okay
I saw Ukranian question I'm gonna
address that one because that's where
I'm living
ah it flew by me where to go where to go
okay shoot
oh here we go
would you like to move to the other city
in Ukraine
I love Lavigne for example live in Hart
cave good question I'm pretty grounded
here in and keeve I have a good
apartment to get up and move right now
to another Ukrainian city it's not
happening honestly my days are about
just getting up early and focusing on
the work and that's that's where that's
where everything it is I'm not even
social these days and hardly doing
anything outside of my apartment but
just focusing on the work and to move to
a new city will be a distraction I've
been too hard cave great city made a
video on it
loved it guys guys from Pakistan or USA
or whomever is here check this video on
Harkov Ukraine have you heard of it
probably not
that's a cool place awesome architecture
and clean as far as Ukrainian cities go
it's the cleanest one I've seen loved it
l'viv is nice l'viv is more european
it's more let's say textured and details
more just more European feeling I
especially liked heart cave though great
place
kiba's the capital guys so if you don't
know Ukraine well keeve is is the nerve
center Kiev is a proper mix of
everything architectural styles
languages ideologies it's a wild place
ok joker
w x7 did I ever go to Syria yeah I did
2008 and I went to Syria because I
wanted to meet Iraqis because in 2008
Syria was the safe haven I was at a
nightclub at 3 in the morning and this
guy from Lebanon was on the the
turntables making the music and he was a
student and he was in Damascus because
that was where it was safe and the
Iraqis were there because it
safe and this is a theme I like to I
haven't expanded I want to expand on it
more in my work but look everything's
temporary and what was safe then turned
unsafe and people you know parts of Iraq
became safer right in parts of Lebanon
became safer but the world is very title
things things flow and change and the
information usually is only about the
last worst time so for example if you
say Bosnia Sarajevo in America people
are gonna have a bad impression because
there's a war there but that was long
ago years ago longer than that
Sarajevo now is cool to travel to it all
changes ok guys a little bit more here I
wanted to mention I think I got it all
one thing I didn't totally touch on but
I get asked a lot is the cultural
differences within Pakistan and I'm just
gonna bring out one example of Pashtun
sand and Punjabis it's like if I'm gonna
compare to the states we don't have that
because we don't have well it's three
lifetimes old all right that's all the
country is that young it's three
lifetimes and no Mississippi in
California are different places in many
ways it's not like that deep it's not
like in the food and the music and I
mean it's in the food some actually I
correct myself it isn't the food in the
music a little but not nearly at the
levels of like the Pashtun and the
Punjabis it's like two universes away I
mean they can get along fine but you you
know Pashtuns usually do certain types
of work the certain times of food
religiously they're a bit different at
school that's what's cool about
traveling
Christiaan Joker Asus yeah I am
technically I was born Christian born
Protestant went to church growing up I
was a rebellious kid I hated it I goofed
off do I go to church now now I look I
used to be used to think you know it was
sort of silly like how could you believe
in this book how do you know it's true
you know sort of not against it well
sort of against it not like holding
judgment but like oh that's silly I
won't have no part of it right and then
I lived with this family in the south of
Ukraine my first youtube series called
fish out of water
it was crazy guys I moved to the
countryside in with a family that were
refugees from war there on the front
line like living right near the Russian
border their apartment got shelled out
they moved to the countryside I moved in
with them to make a video series and the
first day we wake up and they're doing
all that they're like really passionate
prayers and it was Sunday there's like
30 minutes long and I'm like okay cool
cool and then Monday morning
same thing Tuesday morning same thing it
was every day they're very religious
people he used to be an alcoholic you
know drug you know fighter type and he
found God and he cleaned up completely
any of the most beautiful kids and their
family was so strong cohesive and they
went through all this [ __ ] and now their
life was getting better and I saw it I'm
like that works really well for them
that's that's amazing right and it's
only because religion they could do that
so respect respect to that doesn't mean
I have to believe in it but I get it now
like I don't want to push my values on
anyone I don't think anyone should push
their values on anyone else that's you
know I think everyone has the right to
realize themselves how they want to as
long as they're not harming others
but but that experience really showed me
what a powerful tool Christianity can be
and how it could be like very beneficial
for some people for sure so I'm
Christian but I don't practice what is
my advice for new travel vloggers okay
well I learned the hard way which was by
myself and not knowing what I was doing
at all I'll give you a few few bullet
points really quickly and these are
places I have to improve on to nail down
your title and your thumbnail your
thumbnail is the picture that people see
in YouTube when they're going through
and that's why some of the titles I hate
do and they're a little bit more grabby
than I'd like them to be like there's
this one I did in Balochistan and the
ship breaking yard I said expelled from
Balochistan I was like do I write that
or not like I was not in a bad way it'll
grab more people where people will be
interested in it that's how it works
unfortunately so thumbnails in titles
know what you want to do like and that
might take experimentation like I I want
to show the world in a certain way I
knew that I didn't know how I did all my
cellphone for a while on my mobile phone
now I just use a GoPro a GoPro and a
phone that's it so you don't need the
equipment it's all about this story so
figure out a way where you can really
grab the viewer in the beginning and
then lead them in through a journey and
then have some sort of conclusion I mean
the ideal is like in everything every
Hollywood movie is the hero's journey
right hero hero comes into like some
realization they want to change
something they go into the unknown
they they they fight the dragon they
they they do the hard battle they they
learn their lesson and they come back
almost reborn like if you can wrap that
into a video that's how psychologically
we all think and
like as a humans we all want that so
when I did this crotch I did this video
in Karachi like finding the rapper's and
so I didn't have anything set up and I
wanted to get this element of surprise
so I went in and Lyari is not the
easiest looking neighborhood and it's
got a terrible history because it was
super dangerous about five six years ago
so I wanted to build that tension up a
little I get off I don't know anyone I
got to meet the people I meet the people
I get in we find the rapper's it wasn't
really so much about the rap video like
we only only shot like I don't know a
minute of the rap video but it was like
the journey of getting into that and
then what did I gain out of that I
gained this realization that in the so
called tough neighborhood the people are
cool I made friends but it's hard when
you're doing it this way with no
structure like in the movie youyou
storyboard it and you write out how the
script is gonna be every situation I get
into I don't know how the situation is
going to be now there's some people that
are better performers that are other I'm
not an actor if I was I could probably
build up the tension more you know get
people more excited I think I've
probably gotten better at that because I
am more aware of it but I bring people
into a story man whatever it is bring
people into a story and YouTube is a
long road it's just starting to really
work out for me now and I've put a lot
of videos out there and most of them a
lot of them are trash they're not that
good so it's taken me a long time and I
I've done it all alone maybe it's better
than like know someone that youtubes and
and learn from them and all that stuff I
sort of did it the hard way and that was
probably a slower way but honestly I was
just figuring it out myself and where I
was at in life and all these other
things so do it it's cool how can you
drive in Saudi easy just go to a rental
car place rent a car
I had an international driver's license
I bought online for like 50 bucks and I
didn't even show it so that was easy
okay guy
these are great questions I'm gonna I'm
gonna wind it down here Pakistan
zindabad long live Pakistan
I learned that right when I came into
the country okay Francis Presley stick
up with uplifting the common man in his
plight show similarities common
pleasures and common misfortune you will
be golden
cool Francis thank you thank you for
that yeah I try to go there I try to go
there but I I should focus more on that
good one thank you for that okay
nostalgia why isn't there a chat about
Ukraine or Belarus why are you pandering
so much to a niche fanbase so nostalgia
few reasons one this is only my third
chat my first one was while I back I
don't remember the topic it was open so
I'm really new to this I had a lot of
people ask about this a lot of packets
it do a live chat do a live chat
Ukrainians unfortunately and asked me to
do a live chat so it's new to me doing
this live camp if people want it in in
Ukraine I am all about it I just worry
that I would I would you know I don't
know if they're meant that many people
interested my Ukrainian audience is that
interested in a live chat if they are
let me know and we can talk contact at
Peter Santaniello calm that's my email
best way to get me if you feel like it
obviously but good suggestion I'm gonna
do a bunch of Ukraine after this America
series then I'm going to post in the
next couple weeks that I'm I'm in
Ukraine so my videos will be here and
we'll see how that goes we'll see how
the traction is and if people are
interested in it I'm totally down ok
this is
good one gay hint did the Pakistani
government pay you to come to Pakistan
no no government pay me to come to
Pakistan or anywhere the reason being is
I want to keep all my stuff pure how I
see it
the last thing I want to do is be
crafted into some sort of narrative look
if a government said here's the money do
what you do totally I would be into it
the reason I one of the reasons I went
to that ship breaking yard is to just as
I get those comments all the time just
to dispel that theory that the Pakistani
government's paying me because they
would not pay me to go into a ship
breaking yard where they're burning
asbestos and terrible labor conditions
and it's they're not gonna pay me to do
that obviously
and my first Lahore video I had to
remove some of the content from the
guide because the mullahs and the police
were on him because I showed some things
about a guy that squatted some guy's
house you know government guy and you
know it was pretty bad it like was it
was definitely it shown poorly on let's
say the authorities there and so he made
me remove it because his he was in
jeopardy so now no no payments and
that's that's my promise I'll only take
payments if I can do my style work if I
have to like all of a sudden stage
everything and you know see everything's
amazing and no it's not my thing
the plenty of other people that will do
that I'm not one of them I would rather
make money which I'm figuring out like
through another channel another side
business that funds this work then ever
do this whole like tourist promotion
government work again if Pakistani
government if you're there you want to
fund me to go let me do my thing I'm
down with that
okay guys a few more questions I said
that a few questions ago but they keep
coming so how much money did I spend in
Pakistan is it caught as was it fair
enough it was it was pretty inexpensive
ice I splurged a little more on hotels I
was a little a little bit beat down
because I was making a video every day
and I'd done two weeks prior in India
which will tire any human being if
you're traveling hard through that
country so I was spending like sixty
bucks a night on hotels transports cheap
food is cheap I mean foods what you want
you can go to very nice restaurants pay
a lot you can do street food but I
wasn't spending that much it's if you're
coming in with dollars or euros or again
whatever it's it's very affordable
Kashmir yeah that's one guys I know
that's a very tense region politically I
would like to do both sides
I sort of like doing this both sides
thing I was gonna go to Russia this
summer because I live in Ukraine I've
done a lot of Ukrainian videos and I
want to do Russia it never always makes
me friends for sure but it definitely
provokes thought let's say and shows
people a unique perspective when you can
compare them closely the same person
going in that's why what I do
West Bank or Palestine in Israel Ukraine
Russia Pakistan India I was thinking of
actually doing in Iran Saudi Arabia
similarities and differences video it's
definitely gonna be a tough one but um
some people ask me for that okay
love your work but why are you
approaching the culture through
monetization from YouTube only Pakistan
should profit from Pakistan yeah I mean
that's one way of looking at it another
way is if I didn't make any money I
can't go anywhere and I can't make any
videos so what I make from YouTube
covers my costs and if it made me money
then I'll be happy if it makes me money
for sure because all I do is this stuff
I sacrifice a lot for it it's it all
looks like fun but I take it very very
very seriously when I'm there it's not
it looks like travel but it's like I
want to make the best video for the
viewer and I feel if I can open the
world if I can some of my content can
show people a different aspect of
Pakistan a more positive one then it's
doing something well so if I'm just
going to go in and go broke and any
little bit of money I get from YouTube
give it all away and then not pay my
rent or eat that's not a world I want to
live in then I get what you're saying
give all the money to Pakistan I'm not a
big youtuber but I'm not making tons of
money here so it's covering my costs I
hope to be making a lot more money for
sure like definitely because all I do is
this I've sacrificed relationships for
this I very little social time and I'm
just a one-man show and believe it or
not there's there's a ton of work that
goes on behind this and a lot of
unpleasurable times too so I'm not gonna
give up you know I'm not gonna starve to
do it let's say okay upset stomach in
India or Pakistan no I was sick in
Pakistan I think I might have had Corona
I don't know it was a weird flu it was
it was December it was December I was in
Islamabad I felt
terrible I was in rack that video I
really tried my best to look okay but I
was I was not feeling well but as far as
food poisoning no the only food
poisoning I recall in my life is Taco
Bell Kings Beach California and it freed
those that you don't Ave you that don't
know Taco Bell it's a fast food Mexican
chain in America that's terrible Donita
I had business conferences in Salt Lake
City the next day and I was violently
ill on the streets of Salt Lake City I
had to fly there luckily I got through
the flight Taco Bell has been my worst
food experience on the planet believe it
or not okay guys why do I live in
Ukraine any specific reason Stasi or
stasis start Stasi okay a few reasons
I'll make it short because I could talk
about this subject forever
I had an opportunity I was running my
business remotely in the States and I
was living in San Francisco I came to
Ukraine I'd been in Ukraine before but I
came to keeve three four summers ago I
had one of my best friends living here
another really good friend was here
living for the summer and I visited and
I just saw this city that was like
coming out of it look it over through
its government just like two years prior
to when I came and so it had like this
Renaissance feeling you know you know
all these new murals on the buildings
new restaurants all this music on the
street all this life and my buddies like
you told me to move to Ukraine I did
because he was looking to build a
development team he's like why don't you
live here and I flew back from Kiev to
San Francisco and by the time I landed I
already had a plan in action of how I
was going to move to Ukraine and I mean
I'm an adventurous type one so I love
new experience and I love challenge so
tick that box it's in the world the
history that's made Ukraine a nightmare
politically the geopolitics the region
because it's the basically right
on Russia's doorstep in beteen Europe
there's always been armies going one way
or the other
it's that same geography that lets you
get to the world so if I want to go to
Istanbul hour and 45 minutes if I want
to get to Pakistan it's not even that
crazy of a trip but from the west coast
of America the world is you guys if you
haven't experienced it it is so far away
other than Mexico in Canada right the
world is just a world away and I love
that there's nothing more that I like
than the traveling and being in the
world so that ticked another box the
costs it's one third probably one third
the cost of San Francisco and I just
said why not if it doesn't work out that
I can always move back like I I'm I set
my business it took me a long time and a
lot of work to set it up so I could I
could work remotely and sounds like
doesn't work out I'll go back you only
live once if I can do it now I might
never have this opportunity again I'm
gonna do it so that's why I did it
that's why I moved to Ukraine I like
Slavic culture too I really do I really
like it's the edge of Europe here and
there's there's a there's a special side
to this culture it's people are very
cool doesn't always show on the surface
off the gun but it's a very authentic
place I like it I was always fascinated
with the Soviet Union - growing up I
always was interested in this part of
the world
okay I'll mention this once because I
actually haven't seen a much do I get
offended when people call me Johnny
since no I'm actually surprised that the
world and the amount of young people in
the world know who Johnny census that's
more of a mind twister Pakistan in Iran
were the two countries where I ate I was
called that multiple times a day
seriously on the streets but do I take
an offense by it now I don't I don't
care what's the music in your videos bro
okay mister criteria
that's a very big challenge with making
videos is getting the right music if you
go into any of my videos the music in
that video is if you go see more in the
description I leave the links to the
music
now it's hard finding good copyright
free music sometimes I use a service
epidemic sound there's another there
there's some other artists that have
been providing me music I used
SoundCloud sometimes there's a way to go
through a copyright free like if you
toggle on the left there's a way to do
copyright free music sometimes you can
find something in there it's a lot of
searching Robert Shaw Robert Shaw shout
out to Robert Shaw he used I used his
songs mostly in the Pakistan series song
called on the road really cool song it's
in the descriptions he's a guy out of
the UK making music he's just really
passionate he's actually making a song
for me now for this California series
I'm making so it's probably the music's
a challenge yeah those those are the
places I look though because so much of
its sound the copyright free stuff
sounds so generic and it really makes
the video or not - and I'm not gonna say
I always get the right music I am Robert
and pumped with your song I don't always
get it right but I you know work in
progress yeah many youtubers who have a
channel dedicated copy of free music
yeah epidemic sound is one of the
companies it's just I haven't found that
much good stuff on there to be honest
and he plans to come to him on would
love to come to him on yes we'd love to
no plans though
hey guys I'm gonna wrap it up here Oh
below chest and question I gotta answer
that one where'd that go okay the reason
you were not led into Balochistan is
because the atrocities committed by the
Pakistan military most likely you were
probably followed by the Intel agencies
since your arrival I don't think I was I
think there are times where I came into
contact with them but I don't think I
was followed the whole time I think it
was followed more in Iran to be honest
Balochistan I am aware of the history
what was surprising was there were there
was no checkpoint where we had to show
anything passports or documentation
visas because you do need special
permission I honestly was doing some
research like what's a cool story I can
get up a crotchy oh there's the ship
breaking yard and ship written this it's
really interesting like on spiring shots
and it's near the ocean or on the sea
and okay there could be a close story in
that and then I wasn't aware I needed a
permit to go there to be honest and
there was no like I'm like you know if
there is a permit and I don't have it
okay what's the worst I get I get sent
back home and you know back to Karachi
and that's a failed mission okay I'm
fine with that but there was there was
no checking of that stuff which was
interesting you can't go to these places
out with without military okay yeah I
did but yeah it's probably not the right
thing to do I can't always get it right
I'll tell you that like doing this type
of work you got to make something
interesting enough for the viewer you
got to make a story and sometimes there
are some some gray zones let's say so I
went when I went out there to the ship
breaking yard
I didn't hop a fence there were no no
trust passing signs in either language I
walked to the beach I talked to the guy
on the beach I wasn't trying to sneak
around or hide if they said leave Leave
I would have left they said talk to the
so I wouldn't talk to the boss the boss
says okay we'll show you around a little
bit but then you gotta go and that's
what happened so maybe it's it's not
nearly as dramatic as it looked
let's say okay good question get this
one a lot
walk us what do you think about Scylla
female visitor and Pakistan is it safe
there female vloggers who have made this
rosey something she made some cool
videos about traveling Pakistan as if
solo female look at look at her and some
other female vloggers there they'll tell
you better than me but I think it's I
think it's fine I think it's fine I mean
there's there probably some a few places
you might want not want to go but it's
very clear and it's very obvious so I
don't think it should hold you back
alright guys that's going to be it
really appreciate it this is fun
answering the questions connecting with
you guys
I have a video I'll be posting Sunday
the best of Pakistan if you haven't seen
my 10 part series on Pakistan all
different parts of the country there's a
playlist down below this video or I'll
have it there you can check them out if
you want to be surprised by scenery go
to the huns of valley one if you want to
be surprised by a hospitality Peshawar
if you they're all cool actually I like
them all I'm happy with them all or
Lahore the first day that was just
completely out of this world that
stuff's all there coming up here I'm
doing a series on America stuff my wife
and I shot last fall California Northern
California this will be surprising
guaranteed if you haven't been to that
part of the world because it's very it's
very much mixed up and I'm gonna show
both sides of it let's say and then I'll
be doing a bunch of stuff on Ukraine
because I mean Ukraine and I don't
really feel like getting on a plane
now I don't even think we we can't like
their airplanes airports not functioning
and it's it's not a time to get out in
the world and be shooting travel videos
I just don't feel it I don't want to do
it
but I got plenty here of stories here in
Ukraine that I've wanted to do for a
while it's like I've pushed it off
because I live here it's like oh you can
always get that right I was supposed to
be in Lebanon and Syria you know doing
those videos now but I'm actually
catching up on all my content and I'll
have a lot from Ukraine again thank you
guys for all the support the views the
likes the the comments the super chats
it's cool to have all you without all
you I wouldn't be able to do this and
I'm really grateful for that so until
next video peace have a good day night
evening wherever you're at
take care